Apple just shocked the world by
releasing the 20/20 iPad pro this
morning and I say shocked because we're
in the middle of a pandemic and not only
that but the way they priced the new
iPad pro for the specs it gets tells us
that even those people who are planning
to buy the 2018 model on sale when the
2020 model comes out should actually
just buy this new iPad pro instead
before it goes out of stock by using the
link below and we'll get into why you
should buy the new model in just a
minute although there aren't as many
changes with this year's iPad pro the
changes are actually significant it's
got the same great display as before
with promotion technology which means
that yes it actually has a 120 Hertz
display which makes browsing using the
Apple pencil and playing 120 FPS games
the best experience you can get on any
mobile device it's now packin studio
quality microphones just like Apple
packed into the 16 inch MacBook Pro so
it's going to be great for those who use
FaceTime for their business or maybe
even for podcasting is packing a
four-speaker stereo system just like
before but knowing Apple the quality is
surely going to improve and we'll be
testing it in just a few days and when
we get our hands on it because yes we've
already ordered one so make sure to
subscribe and enable notifications so
you don't miss out it now features a 10
megapixel ultra wide camera which is
totally overkill for a tablet but hey
it's pretty great that you're getting it
for the same price it also packs a 12
megapixel main camera which is most
likely packing the same hardware as the
iPhone 11 Pro which we know takes
incredibly good photos and 4k video on
the front side we're getting the same 7
megapixel true depth selfie camera for
portrait selfies and 1080p 60fps video
and of course that means it gets face ID
authentication which works great on the
iPad pro because you can use it in any
orientation even upside-down now the
biggest deal is that it now gets a brand
new lidar scanner on the back for
insanely accurate depth sensing this not
only means that we should expect to get
insanely good portrait photos on the
rear camera if it supports it but it
also means that this iPad pro is going
to support the best augmented reality
we've seen on
any mobile device we know that because
lidar is actually what a bunch of
companies are using for self-driving
cars so it's the best tech out there for
depth sensing and object tracking so
those interested in augmented reality
should seriously be buying the iPad pro
for performance it now packs a new a 12
Z processing chip with an 8 core
graphics processor and a new enhanced
thermal design to make sure it stays
cool now we're not sure why it's not the
a 13 X chip maybe it means that
processing performance won't go up by
that much but if it doesn't that's okay
because the 2018 model is still overkill
for a lot of the apps on the App Store
either way we're gonna compare the
performance of the 2018 iPad pro to the
new model in just a few days when we get
our hands on it the battery on the 11
inch iPad pro is now twenty eight point
six five watt hours just slightly
smaller than the twenty nine point four
five watt hour battery in the 2018 model
but Apple is still rating it at the same
10 hours of battery life so that means
they improve the efficiency of the new
chip a huge feature is that it now
supports Wi-Fi 6 so it's going to be
future proof for a while supporting the
best Wi-Fi speeds you can get you also
get the same silver or Space Gray color
options the weight is basically the same
at just over a pound and it's exactly
the same 5.9 millimeters thick now
here's where the real magic comes in its
price at the exact same $800 but now it
comes with 128 gigs of storage twice as
much as before at the same price and the
even crazier thing is that if you
upgrade to 256 gigs of storage
it's priced at $900 whereas the 2018
model with that much storage was
actually 950 dollars so it's an even
better deal in the story's the same if
you choose the one terabyte storage
model it's now $1300 instead of 1350 on
the 2018 model now a lot of people were
waiting on the 2020 model just so they
could get the 2018 on sale but to be
honest the pricing on the new model is
so good with 128 gigs of storage that we
would honestly recommend just buying the
20/20 iPad pro even if you can get the
2018 model for $600 on sale brand new
but to our surprise the cheapest you can
find the 2018 model with only 64 gigs of
storage is seven hundred and seventy
nine dollars on Amazon so it's actually
a much worse deal than the new one
especially since it has all the new
features and ever since I pad OS came
out with external storage and file
management support we've been
recommending people to not buy the 64
gig model because it's simply not enough
so the new 20/20 iPad pro with 128
gigabytes of storage is perfect at the
$100 price so make sure to use those
links down below to order before they're
out of stock but wait there's more not
only did Apple release the iPad pro but
they've also announced the new magic
keyboard coming in May which has a
special hinge that allows the iPad pro
to float in the air it now also features
pass-through charging which is huge
because it frees up your iPad pros USB C
port for other things and it features a
full-size magic keyboard with
backlighting and the new scissor switch
keys that we love on the 16 inch macbook
pro the best part is that it now comes
with a trackpad with multi-touch gesture
support like we get on mac books and
coming on March 24th is iPad OS 13.4
which features true cursor support for a
variety of iPad models this is going to
be the biggest change the iPad has ever
seen since the very first iPad the
cursor is now contextual so what changes
depending on what you're hovering over
and when you switch to the touch screen
the cursor disappears until you touch
the trackpad again not only that but
iPad OS 13.4 gives you the same cursor
support with Apple's Magic Mouse too and
Magic Trackpad too
the only downside is that this new
incredible magic keyboard costs $300 for
either of the 11 inch iPad pro models
now I know that's a lot of money but you
could still use the regular smart
keyboard or any third-party keyboard
with the new iPad pro so you're not
forced to spend that much money and by
the way we have a video comparing the
best smart keyboards currently out there
which you can check out after this video
and there are actually some keyboards
coming soon like the Bridge Pro Plus
which also packs
Trackpad so you can save some cash by
going with that but the new magic
keyboard is honestly better because it
has the new floating iPad hinge in any
case if you're not sure which one to buy
you can just buy the iPad pro right now
and wait a while to get the keyboard and
one last thing Apple's new marketing
video for the new iPad pro on YouTube
sarcastically says that it's not a
computer which I find pretty funny and
ironic because years ago they made a
marketing video that said it was a
computer and it ended up getting a lot
of backlash you can check out Apple's
new video right over there and be sure
to click the circle above to subscribe
so you don't miss out on a hands-on
comparison video against the 2018 iPad
pro thanks for watching and we'll see
you in the next video
[Music]